PERINO.
"THE FIVE"
>> IT'S DAY TWO IN NEIL GATE.
BOTH SIDES LINEUP ON OPPOSITE
ENDS OF THE FIELD.
FIRST IT'S DONALD TRUMP DOING
DONALD TRUMP.
President: YOU HAVE TO STAND
PROUDLY FOR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM
OR YOU SHOULDN'T BE PLAYING, YOU
SHOULDN'T BE THERE, MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE COUNTY.
YOU HAVE TO STAND PROUDLY FOR
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THE NFL OWNERS HAVE DONE THE
RIGHT THING.
>> IF THAT'S THE STORY, HAVE YOU
PUSHED IT FORWARD TO A
CONCLUSION?
President: I THINK THE PEOPLE
PUSHED IT FORWARD.
I BROUGHT IT OUT.
THE PEOPLE PUSH IT DID FORWARD.
>> ANOTHER HARDIN TER VIEW.
GIVE THAT GUY A RAZOR SOMETHING
TO STAND ON.
>> BRUTAL.
>> YOU EXPECT THAT FROM TRUMP.
HE FINDS A ISSUE AND TAKES A
HARD LINE STANCE.
LESS.
HE'S YOUR UNCLE, UNCLE SAM.
THAT DIDN'T STOP THE PEARL
CLUTCHERS FROM CLUTCHING THEIR
PEARLS.
>> IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
>> IF YOU HAVE THE POSITION TO
DO IT, DO IT.
>> IT'S ABSURD.
HE DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THE LEADER
OF THE FREE WORLD.
>> REMEMBER HOW THIS STARTED.
SPEAKING TO A CROWD WHITE
FOOTBALL CROWD, CALLING THEM SOB
SKP *Z SAYING THEY SHOULD BE
FIRED.
IN WHAT WORLD OTHER THAN HIS IS
THAT OKAY?
>> AMERICA.
THEY MISS THE POINT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IS A RIGHT HELD
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT.
A PRIVATE ENTITY LIKE THE NFL,
THEY OWN IT AND MAKE THE RULES.
AS LONG AS THERE IS NO
DISCRIMINATION THE TEAMES CAN
MANDATE THE TEAMS PLAY IN HIGH
HEELS AND THE REVERIES WORK IN
TUTUS.
THE PLAYERS CAN PROTEST BUT THEY
WILL BE PENALIZED IF IT'S DONE
DURING A GAME.
PENALIZED NOT JAILED.
THE PLAYERS ARE EMPLOYEES AT
WORK DISOBEYING A RULE.
WHERE ARE YOU IN ALL OF THIS?
WHERE YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN,
SCRATCHING YOUR HEAD.
YOU PREFER UNIT OVER CONFLICT.
YOU DON'T MIND DISSENT.
IT'S THE DISSENSION.
MIND YOU YOU ENJOY A GOOD
DEBATE.
THAT'S WHY YOU WATCH "THE FIVE."
THIS IS LIKE TURNING ON THIS
SHOW AND SEEING ME AND DANA
PLAYING BAD
PLAYING BATMITON FOR AN HOUR.
AND SEEING ME IN TIGHT WHITE
SHORTS IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR 5
5:00 P.M.
>> OR EVER.
>> GLASS HOUSES, TINY DANCER.
GLASS HOUSES.
>> I'M NOT SCARED.
ALRIGHT.
JESSE, WELCOME BACK.
YOU HAD STREP THROAT.
WE MISSED YOU.
>> YES, TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
I WAS SICK OF WINNING.
>> TIRED OF WINNING.
>> A PURELY NATURAL VACATION.
>> YES.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
>> I READ "REASON" MAGAZINE.
THEY SAY THE NFL BOWED TO TRUMP.
I FELT THEY WANTED TO NIP THIS
IN THE BUD.
>> I DON'T READ REASON.
I READ THE WEEKLY STANDARD.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GAVE ME A
SUBSCRIPTION FOR.
NOBODY IS TRAMPLING ANYONE'S
CONSTITUTIONS AL RIGHTS.
THEY'RE EMPLOYEES LIKE US AT
INFORMATION NEWS.
THIS ARE RULES.
HR RULES, PR RULES.
AFTER AWHILE PEOPLE CHANGE THE
CHANNEL AND THE RATINGS WOULD
DIP, THE COMPANY CEO WOULD SAY
CAN YOU STOP DOING THAT.
IF YOU SAY NO, YOU'RE FIRED.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
YOU WEAR THEIR JERSEY, YOU'RE IN
THEIR STADIUM, YOU PLAY FOR
THEIR TEAM.
THEY CAN TELL WHAT YOU TO DO OR
WHAT NOT TO DO.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA TRUMP ISN'T
GOING TO DEPORT PLAYERS.
HE'S SAYING LOVE IT OR LEAVE IT
HE LIKES THE COUNTRY SO MUCH.
IT'S HYPERBOLA.
THE KNEELING THING HURT.
SPEAK YOUR MIND ON ESPN, FOX
NEWS, TWITTER.
ON SUNDAY PLAY FOOTBALL.
IT HURT.
IT HURT THE COMMISSIONER, HE WAS
HIT HARD BECAUSE OF HIS
RESPONSE.
IT HURT THE PLAYERS.
SOME OF THE PLAYERS THAT KNEELED
ARE FREE AGENTS AND HAVING A
HARD TIME GETTING RESIGNED.
IT HURT THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY SIDEPUGH WITH 75% OF THE
COUNT ROW.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD THING AND
I'M GLAD IT'S RESOLVED.
>> ANOTHER ARGUMENT FOR NOT
DETP-PING THE NFL -- DEFENDING
THE NFL BAND THIS.
IS LIKE SHUTTING DOWN SPEAKERS
ON CAMPUS.
YOU'RE A SNOW FLAKE IF YOU DON'T
WANT THEM TO NEIL.
>>
NEIL.>>
KNIL.>>
KNEE.>>
KNEEL.>> I SAW THAT TODAY.
I DON'T THINK THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD TELL PRIVATE COMPANIES
WHAT TO DO.
I'M FOR.
THAT COLLEGES ARE MEANT TO BE
PLACES FOR FRO EXPRESSION.
MOST OF THEM GET TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
I GUESS YOU CAN SAY THE NFL
SHOULDN'T GET TAXPAYER DOLLARS
FOR STADIUM FUNDS.
I'M FOR THAT TOO. THE NFL IS TO
PLAY FOOT PAUL.
YOU DON'T EXPECT A FREE EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS LIKE A COLLEGE CAMPUS.
>> FREE EXCHANGE OF HELMETS TO
THE HEAD.
MARIE, YOU CAN'T SAY THIS IS
DISCRIMINATING IF IT APPLIES TO
EVERYONE, CORRECT?
>> I THINK WHAT THE NFL DIDN'T
DO CORRECTLY, IN MY OPINION.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY
COMMUNICATED ADEQUATELY WITH THE
PLAYER ASSOCIATION BEFORE THEY
RELEASED THIS.
NOW THERE IS A FIGHT OF
INDIVIDUAL PLAYERS AND THE NFL.
I KNOW THEY WANT THIS OUT OF THE
WAY BEFORE THE NEXT SEASON, I
GET THAT.
IT HAS RESEEDED FROM THE
HEADLINES.
IF THEY COORDINATED THIS AND HAD
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THIS.
IS THE MAN.
WE WILL FINE PLAYERS IF THEY
KNEEL.
WE WILL ALSO TAKE THE FIVE
COMMUNITY ACTIVISM STEPS PLAYERS
HAVE ASKED FOR.
IT SEEMS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BETTER WAY TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS,
THROW MORE GASOLINE ON THE FOYER
OF A CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE.
I THINK THE NFL COULD OF HANDLED
THIS BETTER.
NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THE
OWNER OF THE JETS SAYING HE WILL
PAY THE FINE IF HIS PLAYERS GET
THEM.
HE WON'T PASS IT ON.
HE WANTS HIS PLAYERS TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES.
>> THAT'S A INTERESTING POINT,
KG.
IT PUNS THE OWNNESS ON THE OTHER
OWNERS.
IT'S THE OWNERS OWNNESS.
IT'S THE OWNNESS ON THE OWNERS.
NOW THE JETS ARE DOING IT,
SHOULD WE DO IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
WILL THE STRUGGLE CONTINUE.
>> YES, A EMPLOYING PRESSURE.
PROBABLY A SIMPLER TERM TO USE,
YOU STRUGGLED DEEPLY WITH THAT.
HE WILL DO THAT, WHAT ABOUT THE
REST OF YOU?
SHOW UP.
PAY UP.
I A GROW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THIS.
THEY'RE PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR A PRIVILEGE TO PLAY IN ONE
OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST SPORTS.
ONE I LOVE TO WATCH AS WELL.
THIS IS A TIME FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND ACTIVISM.
I LOVE IT EXPRESS YOUR SELF
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE FOUGHT FOR IN
THIS COUNTRY.
SO WE CAN SIT HERE WITH CRAZY,
INSANE OPINIONS AT THE TABLE --
>> WHY ARE YOU LOOKING AT ME?
>> A SIDE GLANCE.
ONE EYE AT YOU AND ONE AT GREG.
>> AMAZING HOW SHE DOES THAT.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
I PRACTICE A LOT.
WE'RE PAID A -- WE'RE PAID TO DO
A JOB.
WE WORK FOR THIS COMPANY.
THEY WORK FOR DIFFERENT TEAMS IN
THE NFL.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM DON'T PLAY
THEN.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S TRYING TO SAY.
I LIKE THE USE OF HIGH
I LIKE THE USE OF HYPH
I LIKE THE USE OF HYPERBLY.
THAT WAS EXCELLENT, JESSE.
>> THANK YOU.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THIS HERE GO
PLAY IN CAN THAT.
>> GO PLAY FOR THE FRENCH.
NO UNIFORMS --
>> PUGH NA POINT TOUCH.
>> THE UNDERLYING TRUTH I HAVE A
INKLING EVERYONE WANTS THIS
BEHIND THEM.
EVEN COLONEL EN
EVEN COLINEL EN
EVEN COLIN K EN
EVEN COLIN KAEN
EVEN COLIN KAEPERNICK.
I THINK THEY FEEL, THIS WASN'T
SUPPOSE TO GO THIS LONG.
>> YES.
WE ALL WANT THE SAME THING.
WE'RE ALL FOR AMERICA.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE NFL
TRIED TO DO.
THEY HANDLED IT PRETTY WELL.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT AT SHOULD
POINT DO.
IT NOW, GET IT OVER WITH, OWNERS
MEETING AND MOVE ON.
NOW THEY HAVE LAID OUT THE
POLICY, IF IT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN.
I COULDN'T SEE HOW IT WOULD.
UNLESS YOU'RE THE JETS.
THEY HAVE LAID OUT THE POLICY.
NOW IF YOU DO IT AND GET FIRED
YOU'RE ACTUALLY FOYERING
YOURSELF.
YOU'RE MAKING A CHOICE.
>> YES.
AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER ISSUE, JESSE.
WERE YOU HEAR WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT LAUREL AND YANI.
IT'S LAUREL AND YANI.
>> YES IT'S NOT 50/50.
IT'S LIKE 80/20 IN THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM TALKING
ABOUT RACE AND POLICE BRUTALITY.
IT'S FINE TO BE ABOUT ACTIVISM.
IT'S ABOUT SYMBOLS WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
THEY WEAR THE HAT, WALK OUT OF
CLASS OVER GUNS, DO THE BLACK
POWER THING.
THAT'S FINE.
THEN WE ASK, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
DO, WHAT IS THE SOLUTION.
THEY SAY WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
BUT DON'T OFFER A SOLUTION.
I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WHAT DO THE PLAYERS WANT?
WHAT ARE THEY SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING?
WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS TO POLICE
BRUTALITY AND RACISM.
NOBODY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE.
IT JUST LOOKED UNPATRIOTIC.
>> THE NFL CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
ANOTHER SEASON -- NOT JUST THE
RATINGS BUT THERE ARE MANY
PRESSURES.
PEOPLE WATCHING DIFFERENT
THINGS.
ALSO THIS RECENT DECISION BY THE
SUPREME COURT ABOUT SPORTS
BETTING.
THAT'S A BIGGER ISSUE FOR THE
NFL TO DEAL WITH NOW.
>> ALSO THE BRAIN INJURIES.
>> YES, THAT'S A BIGGER ISSUE
LONG TERM FOR THE NFL.
THERE ARE PLAYERS LIKE MALCOLM
JENKINS, IF YOU WENT TO OHIO
STATE, HE HAS PLANS AND IDEAS OF
HOW TO WORK WITH COMMUNITY
ACTIVISTS AND LAW ENFORCEMENTS.
HE'S DOING THE MEETINGS ON HIS
OWN WITH OTHER PLAYERS.
MORE PLAYERS SHOULD DO THAT LIKE
HE HAS BEEN DOING.
>> YES.
>> LAST WORD, KIMBERLY.
>> THINK THEY SHOULD FOCUS ON
PLAYING FOOTBALL.
IF THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR JOBS.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO
KAEPERNICK.
>> I FEEL BAD ABOUT THE 49ERS.
>> RIGHT.
THEY WERE THE BEST TEAM EVER.
EVERYONE LOOKED UP TO THE 49ERS.
WE HAD THE BEST QUARTER BACKS.
STEVE YOUNG, RONNIE LOTT.